[Music]
on friday the 18th of may
after having seen no land for 23 days we
sighted
lofty mountains we approached the land
but owing to the heavy rain and a
thunderstorm which prevailed while we
were sailing along the coast
our pilot was unable to identify the
exact locality
on sunday we found ourselves close to
some mountains and when we were near
enough for the pilot to recognize them
he told us that they were above calcutta
and
that this was the country we desired to
go to
we anchored about a league and a half
from the shore after we were at anchor
four boats approached us from the land
who asked us what nation we were
and they then pointed out calcutta to us
on the following day these same boats
came again alongside when the captain
major sent one of the convicts to
calcutt
the first greeting that he received was
in these words
may the devil take thee what brought you
hither they asked what he sought so far
away from home
and he told them that we came in search
of christians
and spices we were greatly astonished to
hear the people talk
for we never expected to hear our
language spoken so far away from
portugal
[Music]
the city of calcutt is inhabited by
christians
they are of a tawny complexion some of
them have big beards and long hair
whilst others clip their hair short or
shave the head merely allowing a tuft to
remain on the crown as a sign that they
are
christians they also wear mustaches
they pierce the ears and wear much gold
in them they go naked
down to the waist covering their lower
extremities with very fine cotton stuffs
but it is only the most respectable who
do this for the others manage as best
they are able
the women of this country as a rule are
ugly and of small stature
they wear many jewels of gold around the
neck numerous bracelets on their arms
and rings
set with precious stones on their toes
all these people are well disposed
and apparently of a mild temper though
at first sight they seem
covetous and ignorant
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
so this week i'm going to get coco to
recommend a documentary for magellan tv
so what do you think coco the big cats
the dog for every job
animal exploration what do you think
coco
last confessions of the cannibal
weird coco luckily magellan has over 3
000 documentaries
so there are plenty of options for
example india's lost world
a fascinating exploration of the
mysterious tribes
of north india and you can now take
advantage of an exclusive offer
30 off an annual membership this gives
you an entire year for less than 3.50 a
month
even if you've joined magellan before
and lapsed
you can simply click on the link in the
description to claim your discounted
membership today
thanks
when we arrived at calcutt the king was
15 leagues away the captain major sent
two men to him with a message
informing him that an ambassador had
arrived from the king of portugal with
letters
and that if he desired he would take
them to where the king was
the king presented the bearers of this
message with much fine cloth
he sent word to the captain bidding him
welcome saying that he was about to
proceed to calcutta
as a matter of fact he started at once
with a large retinue
[Music]
on the following morning the captain
major set out to speak to the king
and took with him 13 men of whom i was
one
we put on our best attire placed
bombards in our boats
and took with us trumpets and many flags
on landing the captain major was
received
by many men armed and unarmed the
reception was friendly
as if the people were pleased to see us
though at first appearance looked
threatening for they carried naked
swords in their hands
a palinkin was provided for the captain
major such as is used by men of
distinction in that country
as also by some of the merchants who pay
something to the king for the privilege
attended by all these people we took the
road of calcutta and came first to
another town
called capua the captain major was there
deposited at the house of a man of rank
while we others were provided with food
consisting of rice
with much butter and excellent boiled
fish
when we arrived at calcutt they took us
to a large church
and this is what we saw
the body of the church is as large as a
monastery all built with hume stone and
covered with tiles
at the main entrance rises a pillar of
bronze as high as a mast
on the top of which was perched a bird
apparently a [ __ ]
in addition to this there was another
pillar as high as a man and very stout
in the center of the body of a church
rose a chapel all built of hume stone
with a bronze door sufficiently wide for
a man to pass
and stone steps leading up to it within
this sanctuary stood a small image on
which they said
represented our lady along the walls by
the main entrance hung seven small bells
in this church the captain major said
his prayers and we with him
we did not go within the chapel for it
is the custom that only certain servants
of the church called
quaffies should enter these quaffies
wore some threads passing over the left
shoulder
and under the right arm in the same
manner as our deacons wear the stole
they threw holy water over us and gave
us some
white earth which the christians of this
country are in the habit of putting on
their foreheads
breasts around their neck and on the
forearms
they threw holy water upon the captain
major and gave him some of the earth
which he gave in charge of someone
giving them to understand that he would
put it on later
many other saints were painted on the
walls of the church wearing crowns
they were painted variously with teeth
protruding an inch from the mouth and
four of five arms
[Music]
the king was in a small court reclining
upon a couch covered with a cloth of
green velvet
above which was a good mattress and upon
this again a sheet of cotton stuff
very white and fine more so than any
linen the cushions were after the same
fashion
in his left hand the king held a very
large golden cup
having a capacity of half an almode at
its mouth this cup was two palmers wide
into this cup the king threw the husks
of a certain herb which is chewed by the
people of this country because of its
soothing effects
and which they call a tambour on the
right side of the king stood a basin of
gold
so large that a man might just encircle
it with his arms
this contained the herbs there were
likewise many silver jugs
the canopy above the couch was all guilt
[Music]
the captain on entering saluted in the
manner of the country by putting
the hands together then raising them
towards heaven as is done by christians
when addressing god
and immediately afterwards opening them
and shutting the fists quickly
the king beckoned to the captain with
his right hand to come nearer but the
captain did not approach him for it is
the custom of the country for no man to
approach the king
except only the servant who hands him
the herbs
when the king beckoned to the captain he
looked at us others
and ordered us to be seated on a stone
bench near him where he could see us he
ordered the water for our hands should
be given us
was also some fruit one kind of which
resembled a melon
except that its outside was rough and
the inside sweet
whilst another kind of fruit resembled a
fig
and tasted very nice and the captain
told him he was the ambassador of a king
of portugal
who was lord of many countries and the
possessor of great wealth of every
description
exceeding that of any king of these
parts that for a period of 60 years
his ancestors had annually sent out
vessels to make discoveries in the
direction of india
as they knew there were christian kings
there like themselves
this he said was the reason which
induced them to order the country to be
discovered
not because they sought for gold or
silver for this they had such abundance
that they needed not what was to be
found in this country
there reigned a king whose name was dom
manuel
who had ordered him to build three
vessels of which he had been appointed
captain
major and who had ordered him not to
return to portugal
until he should have discovered the king
of the christians
on pain of having his head cut off
and finally he had been instructed to
say by word of mouth that he
the king of portugal desired to be his
friend
and brother
on tuesday the captain got ready the
following things to be sent to the king
12 pieces of lambeau 174 scarlet hoods
six hats four strings of coral a case
containing six
wash hand basins a case of sugar two
casks of oil
and two of honey and as it is the custom
not to send anything to the king without
the knowledge of the more
his factor and of the bail the captain
informed them of his intention
they came and when they saw the present
they laughed at it saying it was not a
thing to offer a king that the poorest
merchant from mecca or any other part of
india gave more
and that if you wanted to make a present
it should be in gold as the king would
not accept such things
when the captain heard this he grew sad
and said that he had brought no gold
that moreover he was no merchant but an
ambassador
that he gave of that which he had which
was his own private gift and not the
kings
that if the king of portugal ordered him
to return he would entrust him with far
richer presence and that if king camelim
would not accept these things
he would send them back to the ships
upon this
they declared that they would not
forward his presence nor consent to his
forwarding them
himself when the captain saw that they
were determined not to forward his
present
he said that as they would not allow him
to send his present to the palace he
would go to speak to the king
and would then return to the ships
when he had entered the king said that
he had expected him on tuesday
the captain said that the long road had
tied him and that for this reason he had
not come to see him
the king then said that he had told him
that he came from a very rich kingdom
and yet he'd brought him nothing to this
the captain rejoined that he had brought
nothing because the object of his voyage
was merely
to make discoveries the king then asked
what it was he had come to discover
stones or men if he'd come to discover
men is he said why he brought nothing
moreover he had been told that he
carried with him the golden image of a
santa maria
the captain said that the santa maria
was not of gold and that even if she
were
he would not part with her as she had
guided him across the ocean
and would guide him back to his own
country the king then asked what kind of
merchandise was to be found in his
country
the captain said there was much corn
cloth iron bronze and many other things
the king asked whether he had any
merchandise with him
the captain replied that he had a little
of each sort as samples
and that if permitted to return to the
ships he would order it to be landed the
king said no
he might take all his people with him
securely more his ships
land his merchandise and sell it to the
best advantage
having taken leave of the king the
captain returned to his lodgings
and we with him as it was already late
no attempt was made to depart
that night
[Music]
in this manner all on board ship went on
land in twos and threes
taking with them bracelets cloths new
shirts and other articles
which they desired to sell we did not
however
affect these sales at the prices hoped
for when we arrived in mozambique
for a very fine shirt which in portugal
fetches 300 rays
was here worth only two fanos which is
equivalent only to 30 rays
for 30 rays in this country is a big sum
and just as we sold
shirts cheaply so we sold other things
in order to take some things away from
this country
if only for samples wednesday the 29th
of august
the captain major and the other captains
agreed that in as much as we had
discovered the country that we had come
in search of
as also spices and precious stones and
it appeared
impossible to establish cordial
relations with the people
it would be as well to take our
departure
and it was resolved that we should take
with us the men whom we detained
as on our return to calcutta they might
be useful to us
in establishing friendly relations we
therefore set sail and left for portugal
greatly rejoicing at our good fortune
and having made so great a discovery
[Music]
you